dimanche soir un homme de 24 ans est
mort mort en service pour nous protéger
des émeutes et de ses conséquences il
s'appelait Dorian d'un Malincourt et
était sapeurs-pompiers
[Applaudissements]
et désolé de vous dire que c'est tout
sauf hors sujet chers collègues parce
que depuis mardi dernier ce sont bien
808 policiers pompiers et gendarmes qui
ont été blessés à ceux qui crient au
soi-disant permis de tuer de nos forces
de l'ordre je le dis solennellement ils
ont et ils méritent notre soutien pour
leur action
parce que
la vérité mes chers collègues c'est que
oui le décès brutal d'un jeune homme ce
sera toujours un drame mais il est sans
rapport avec le déferlement de violence
brûlé nos bâtiments publics des écoles
des mairies des bibliothèques tirées
avec des armes de guerre sur nos
policiers attendez à la vie de nos élus
et de leur famille piller des commerces
il y a aucune justice dans ses actions
et quand on est un responsable politique
on ne fait pas le tri entre ce qui peut
être brûlé ce qui ne peut pas l'être à
ceux qui osent dire que la fin justifie
les moyens à ceux qui ont des refuser
d'appeler au calme vous serez jugés
sévèrement par les Français nous devons
avoir un discours de vérité évidemment
pour les parents évidemment pour nos
jeunes qui doivent prendre conscience de
leurs actes et de ses conséquences un
discours de vérité aussi face à ceux qui
à l'extrême droite veulent faire croire
que nos quartiers se résumeraient à 7000
voyous armés venus pour casser nous leur
disons qu'ils ne sont pas et qu'ils le
font pas nos quartiers parce que les
Français qui vivent dans nos quartiers
ce sont les premiers à pleurer devant
nos écoles détruites ce sont les
premiers à souffrir des dégradations et
ce sont les premières respecter la règle
à respecter la République et à aimer la
France merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
quels sont les actions que votre
gouvernement va continuer à prendre pour
faire respecter notre République
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Aurore Bergé il y a une
semaine jour pour jour un jeune homme de
17 ans a été tué lors d'un contrôle
routier mais bien vite après ce drame
l'émotion légitime a été remplacée par
une violence inexcusable ce sont d'abord
les symboles de la République et de
leorité qui ont été spécifiquement visés
notamment les mairies les écoles les
commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie ce sont ensuite des pillages
de magasins qui ont éclaté et dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche la violence
est montée d'un cran avec l'attaque du
domicile du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses et
j'ai à nouveau une pensée pour Vincent
Jean Brun son épouse et ses enfants
face à ces violences notre priorité
c'est le retour de l'ordre républicain
et notre réponse s'est appuyée sur
quatre piliers d'abord la mobilisation
des forces de l'ordre avec 45 000
policiers gendarmes sur le terrain
deuxième pilier la fermeté de la réponse
pénale ensuite la responsabilité des
réseaux sociaux et enfin un rappel
nécessaire de la responsabilité et de
l'autorité parentale car les auteurs
sont jeunes voire très jeunes nous avons
nous avons agi guidé par un objectif
aucune impunité face aux violences grâce
à cette intervention forte et rapide de
l'état grâce à la mobilisation des élus
locaux les violences ont commencé à
diminuer à partir de samedi avec une
décrue très nette dimanche soir et
encore la nuit passée notre objectif a
été et reste de garantir l'ordre
républicain
nous sommes sur la bonne voie mais nous
restons extrêmement vigilants et c'est
progressivement avec la plus grande
prudence que nous adapterons notre
dispositif de sécurité madame la
Présidente berger avec l'ensemble de la
majorité avec l'ensemble des élus
républicains nous sommes aux côtés des
policiers des gendarmes des
sapeurs-pompiers nous saluons la
mobilisation des magistrats nous sommes
aux côtés des mers et des huiles des
élus locaux qui sont en première ligne
et nous répondrons présents pour les
habitants pour les commerçants les
artisans pour les victimes de ces
violences comme le président de la
République nous y a invité nous devrons
aussi examiner toutes les causes de ces
événements et comme je l'ai dit hier à
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe nous
en tirerons toutes les conséquences avec
les groupes de la majorité et tous les
parlementaires de l'arc républicain je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre femme